[Music]
Chuck I got another explainer for you uh
oh this one this one couldn't wait
okay and it's why things break when they
fall see but this is this is what I've
learned yeah from things you thought you
knew
there are times when in the past at full
disclosure where you have said so we're
going to talk about
floating things that float and in my
head I will say not audibly of course
but I will say
Neil has lost his damn mind
he wants to sit here
and waste people time
talking about why something might float
and I'm like why bro whatever let's okay
let's get into it and then we start
talking about it and by the time it's
over I'm like oh my God okay
so well so here you go and let's let's
do it okay why things break when they
fall yeah so uh
maybe it's obvious to some people but
just I thought I would tease out the
physics of what's going on okay all
right okay so you have a plate that is
up on a shelf okay right it's a
breakable plate all right and somebody
shoves the plate it falls it hits the
ground and breaks it's a cat a cat did
that a cat did that for sure it's always
a cat for sure okay one of my favorite
memes was it a meme where they said we
know the Earth isn't flat because
otherwise cats would have pushed
everything off of it right now I never
saw that but that was good hilarious
that's a really good evidence that Earth
is not flat all right so the plate is in
front of you you actually have to commit
some kind of violence on the plate to do
it okay so what you have to do is ask
how much energy is holding this plate
together
okay all right so you go down to the
molecular level and see how strongly the
molecules are bound are bound to each
other okay so in a crystal for example
they're pretty strongly bound together
so if you try to break a crystal it's
hard it takes more energy to break a
crystal all right and so it's a fragile
sort of dinner plate all right not a
plastic plate but just one that can
break you actually have to
put energy into it and the plate will
not break
unless the energy you put into it is
greater than the binding energy of the
molecules holding the plate together
okay okay that well and that makes sense
that's simple does that make sense it
makes complete sense what what doesn't
make sense right now is binding energy
okay so yeah well I thought those two
words mean exactly what you think they
mean in that sentence so the two
molecules that are adjacent to each
other all right now why doesn't the
plate just separate all by itself by
itself yes something is holding the
molecules together okay it could be any
one of a number of kinds of horses doing
it but nonetheless they're attached to
each other and if you introduce energy
that's greater than the energy that's
holding it together you will break that
Bond
gotcha okay so that's how anything
breaks basically right but we're having
to use dinner plates for this example
all right so if it's just sitting there
in front of you and if you pound on it
you'll break it all right so you had to
put energy in it but wait a minute the
plate that's sitting on a Shelf
that the cat pushed off you're not
pounding on it you didn't pound on the
plate nothing touched that plate okay
did the cat break the plate no the cat
just showed the plate the edge of the
shelf and even if the Cat broke the
plate you know cats they'd have been
like iron break
I don't even know who you're looking at
why are you even looking over here first
of all why are you in my house right now
that's what I'm trying to figure out who
the hell are you and why do you like why
do you show up every day how did you get
a key is what I want to know how did you
get a key to this house
well can I get back to Breaking plates
please anyway anyway so the cat didn't
do anything to the plate the cat didn't
physically break the plate right okay so
what broke the plane this is the
question you know that if you take a
hammer and hit it to a plate it'll break
you know if you pound your fist on the
plate it'll break you'd know all this
okay
why did the plate break when it fell off
the shelf
because it hit the floor
guests yes okay uh okay
um it hit the floor with a certain
amount of energy correct okay and the
higher the location it falls from the
more energy it's going to have does that
make sense of course yeah and you know
what kind of energy that is
uh uh energy of motion so we have a word
for that kinetic kinetic energy exactly
so the kinetic energy of the plate
that it had the instant before it hit
the floor you have to ask how much
energy is that compared to the binding
energy of the plate
all right right and so does that exceed
The Binding energy of the plate and if
it does the plate will break okay where
did the plate get its kinetic energy
from
um gravity gravity okay uh all right but
gravity didn't put the plate on the
Shelf
okay who put the plate on the Shelf
well
I mean
I mean who who lives with the cat
that's who put the plate on the show
yeah because you know okay so so the
plate used to be
at a low location right and somebody
walked up to the plate after it was
clean there was like the lower shelf of
the dishwasher they picked it up
use their energy
to give that plate what's called
gravitational potential energy
okay and the higher you put the plate on
the Shelf the more gravitational
potential energy it has and then the
plate just sits there
in possession of gravitational potential
energy
it just sits there and if you dare put
if the cat pushes the plate off the
shelf the gravitational potential energy
swaps
and becomes kinetic energy
eight okay until it has no gravitational
potential energy left
which is right when it hits the floor
and all that energy becomes kinetic
and this dance between kinetic energy
and gravitational potential energy is
what goes on in every curve and every
turn of a roller coaster
okay other than the first pull up the
top right okay where there's like chains
and Motors everything else is free fall
basically you're in free Glide all right
and so that's why when you go up a hill
you slow down
well why are you slowing down because
the gravitational potential energy is
taking away your kinetic energy
and and once you get to the top why do
you speed up on the way down because the
kinetic energy is taking away is is
being converted from the gravitational
potential energy and your fastest point
on an entire roller coaster
is going to be where
the fastest point yes you mean where you
reach your top speed yes where's that
going to be at the bottom of the first
drop the bottom of the lowest point of
the roller coaster is going to be your
highest kinetic energy and your and your
and your highest potential energy is
obvious now it's going to be whatever is
the highest point on the roller coaster
so the roller coasters fully exploit
this gravity kinetic energy potential
energy relationship okay and all I'm
saying is you want to know who broke the
plate you did because you gave it the
energy to break in the first place by
ascending it to that shelf see how it
sounds to me like you've been talking to
the cat
here's their fault right I was just
introducing you to some gravitational
kinetic energy okay getting rid of some
potential energy and by the way the
broom is over there okay
okay so let's keep going now suppose the
plate fell from an even higher height
okay all right it just doesn't break
into two what happens oh it's shattered
it shatters unless there's some other
sort of structural aspect of it like
like safety glass shatters rather than
just breaks into large pieces that you
always hold safety glass because the
pieces are are so small that one piece
can't go in and like cut your jugular
right you'll just be like surface damage
to your skin uh with safety glass that's
why it breaks into very small pieces
like instantly it's so what so it's
death by a thousand shards instead of
one instead of just one big one that
cuts you in half the putt-put pierces
your aorta all I'm saying is that if
it's higher it gains more kinetic energy
because you gave it more gravitational
potential energy and by the time it hits
the ground it has much more energy to
bake to break the plate with so it
doesn't just break it in three places
it'll break it in a hundred places
there it is
[Music]
nice so that's why things break when
they fall
and Chuck you know why some things just
won't break when they fall because
they're flexible and the energy that
would otherwise go back into the product
to break its bonds goes into the product
to have the product Bend
gotcha that takes energy to do that so
plastic something that's plastic when it
falls it will just bend and the energy
goes into the bending of the of the
structure
so and if you want to make something
that that will that will survive kids
things that fall and just bust apart
into 20 pieces but each piece can then
be put back together the way it was
before
you see so the energy still destroys it
but doesn't break any individual piece
because that energy just cast us casts
to this under well my dishes are made
out of Lego
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
that was brilliant that's just brilliant
I have to say
once again I'm impressed
gotta tell you right now uh you know I
thought at the end of this talk that I
was gonna feel like the cat
what the hell
and just to be clear you could make
something if you wanted to say I want to
make a plate that doesn't break
right all right so you make sure the
binding energy between the molecules of
the plate is greater than the energy
that would that it would be given by the
cat if it fell off a very high shelf in
your home
and this is basically unbreakable for
most things that would happen in your
home and so you could you could
calculate what that energy is and find a
material substance for which that's the
case so that's where you get break
resistant
brake resistant stemware for clumsy wine
drinkers yes
uh so the the material substance of it
has higher resistance to it requires
more energy to break it than what is
normal and typical for a delicate wine
stem I had a job where I had to
demonstrate something that was uh
build as unbreakable at the time
and when you're you're supposed to
demonstrate it within reason
okay
I took it and slammed it down and it
exploded
and I've been said to the people
uh maybe it is break resistant
and those your first and last day on
that job oh
without a doubt
all right so Chuck that was that was
another explainer listen here's the one
thing I know now the Earth is not flat
that's thank you that's what okay that's
if that's your only takeaway that's a
start it's a start
oh yet another explainer brought to you
by Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson here
your personal astrophysicist keep
looking up
thank you